hey guys okay i am backstage actually
literally backstage dance studio and i
caught up with some of the firefighter
bachelors who are going to be performing
on saturday night so first let's bring
in nino hey how's it going okay
now i love this we've got some we've got
some push-ups happening in the
background
this is for a good cause this goes to
the burn foundation but let's be honest
this is good for everybody this is a fun
event for everybody we've been doing
this for 19 years and it's a great way
to change up how charity is done and so
we were fortunate to have firefighters
from all over the valley six departments
as well as a hundred volunteers from
firefighters everywhere as civilians and
we're out here collecting money for our
principal mission which is to help
people after the fire is out help burn
survivors and also
get a lot of toys right well this
happens by us raising money right here
and these guys and one gal have been
amazing prepping and that's what they're
doing today so we've got we have a
bachelorette we have bachelor's uh that
folks can come to this event which is at
chaos at the palms and they can bid
for for time with one of these guys for
time and there's great items that have
been donated by their community so we've
got trips to cabo and staycations at
caesars and cosmo and
tickets to nascar and spas and literally
nights out and show tickets all the fun
well here let's walk over here
because i want to see we've got um
well we got trent here
where'd your umbrella go oh it's right
here so you know on july 9th it's going
to be raining min
okay turns ready and uh and ben here
uh
former strip performer so let's see it
this is what the ladies want to see
there you go
you're welcome ladies you're welcome and
james former firefighter and
doing a little song for us there's going
to be lots of serenading lots of singing
[Music]
lots of sexiness
[Music]
we got sexiness all over the place here
so this is the back stage
sneak peek guys join them saturday night
tickets still available
i'm going to let you just enjoy the view
here as i step out of the camera
okay so just in case you weren't
listening it is happening saturday night
from 7 to 11 p.m it's at chaos inside
the palms tickets are on sale right now
60 bucks and
just a reminder it does all go to the
burn foundation so it's an incredible
organization should be a really fun
night it's for the guys and for the gals
and they gave me a little sneak peek
here at their um at their calendar their
upcoming calendar which is not for sale
yet well you're going to show it off
well i am going to show it off here
let's see what we got let's uh take a
look here at some of these photos and i
told you we got ladies too so gentlemen
gentlemen
there are some beautiful ladies who are
going to be uh
auctioned off on saturday night but i
mean that's a valuable thing right there
[Laughter]
i am going to i'm going to be guarding
this in my life
if sherry was here she would have
already stolen it oh i know she was
already texting me how come you did this
while i was out of the office
all right well i'll share with sherry
but anyway guys and gals saturday night
chaos at the palms looks like it'll be a
fun event it goes to a good cause